American weatherman Scott Rudovsky
goes back to meteorological records for
November 2015 when we went and looked at
the Lightning data we found that there
was lightning that occurred right in the
middle of the burn scar here and so this
is kind of a smoking gun in terms of
what could have been the cause for this
burn scar scott knows that only a mega
lightning strike could set off such a
huge fire many people don't know the
lightning bolts can be really massive
right they're arcing across the sky 200
miles long the longest lightning strike
ever lasted about eight seconds if you
can just imagine I mean good lord the
amount of electrical power it's like a
Ghostbusters movie going off on you
Scot starts to build a picture of how a
firewall produced by a mega lightning
bolt could have created this shape the
prevailing winds are coming from
northeast to southwest in this region
the elevation is higher up here in the
north than it is to the south those two
things combine to suggest the fire would
grow further in the south direction than
in the north direction but Scot still
doesn't have the complete picture he
knows a mega lightning strike could have
ignited the huge firewall something else
might have caused it to stop abruptly to
give the scar its knife-like edges he
finds new data which provides a possible
answer six hours later there was a much
stronger storm that came through the
second storm was accompanied by a band
of torrential rain
this produced enough precipitation to
stop the fire in its tracks and that
would help to explain this sharp edge on
the western side of the burn scar scott
has shown how this unnatural looking
feature could have a natural explanation
but if his make a lightning strike
theory is correct the implications are
terrifying we're so lucky that this six
mile long swath of devastation happened
in the middle of the desert middle of
nowhere instead of say New York I mean
Manhattan was about six miles long 48
years ago New York's entire power grid
went down due to a lightning strike and
that caused 300 million dollars in
damage which sounds like a lot the
remember years ago our life wasn't run
by computers our cars weren't computers
I can't imagine how bad it would be now
to have nine hours of blackout in New
York City